welcome to a bar thank you do i still  have to wear a mask indoors you actually  do not great  well as long as you're vaccinated no i'm  not oh then that's bad well i'm entering  a bar at 11 a.m did you really think i  was vacs because that's on you  you're right i deserve covey just  pausing to see if i can hear actual  crickets  this is like the comedic stylings of  camila harris  [Laughter]  this seems like the white house just  gave them a psa to perform  as comedy and this is one of the  problems for snl  is that comedy should be transgressive  and countercultural and you know  rebellious and kind of kind of that's  what it should be and yes offensive i  mean comedy should be all of those  things  and snl is not that snl is now a  mouthpiece for the elites if i want to  say something funny or witty or do an  impression i will no longer  ever do any of those things